the era is the early 1990s I was aware
of sgml aware of if you like the very
technical usage of it in things like the
texting coding initiative and I'd heard
about Tim berners-lee usage of sgml
technology for web page markup in the
unfortunately named HTML so much better
if you called it just hypertext markup
HTM or even as somebody said Tim's own
tag set t OT how about that but not ml
at the end you have to remember that
it's exactly the same time almost in the
early 90s PDF came about and I was doing
a lot of work with Adobe so there was
this European hypertext meeting in
September 1994 sponsored by the
Association for Computing Machinery
which is basically our professional body
in the States and I thought well it's
all going to be about sgml HTML and all
this kind of thing but just to say that
there are other notations for documents
and other things where you can embed
hyperlinks even I want to talk about PDF
because we were the my group here was I
think the UK's first ever be to test
site for PDF we've got a lot of
experience and I thought just as balance
I'll put in a paper about use of media
and it was accepted so I think the
organizers realized you needed a bit of
a balancing discussion again my talk and
he went down very well although I think
some of them or you know who cares about
appearance Brigade well it wasn't the
PDF is so messy it looks beautiful but
inside it's a mess needs more structure
they just want the mark-up the fact that
you know whether you want to do it in
Times Roman or in Palatino or in Optima
well that's for graphics artists to
worry about all we're concerned is you
know it's a heading so at the end of my
talk I had a lot of very interested
questions because meeting PDF was pretty
new technology but marching up the aisle
towards me and I did recognize him from
photographs it's the only time we've
ever met was Tim berners-lee now certain
and he came up shot my hands here
join that he said you know it won't go
down well with everybody here but he
said I think we're in for a document
universe where we've got to try and make
detailed tight appearance coexist with
structure and it's going to be a
struggle how right he was we're still
struggling with those twenty thirty
years later so he said you know all this
flak I've been getting about calling of
HTML and why couldn't I have done my
homework was thoroughly before I defined
it
he said we're having a panel session
we're going to try and get all these
issues sorted out would you like to come
along so said yeah sure were fine so
went into this big hall there was
parallel panel sessions but this was by
far in a way the most popular believe me
feels I was there it was wonderful and
the front were people two rival armies
almost of people standing up at the
front making that pitch and I classify
them straightaway as either being
theologians or browser pragmatists and
you got to remember that this was two
years after Tim first did the HTML thing
and companies like Netscape who are the
leaders at the time and getting in on
the act Internet Explorer from Microsoft
saw immediately the potential of this
standardized markup which they don't
really was standardized or maybe they
didn't hope because it became very clear
that Netscape and ie having got hold of
this would love to be in a market
dominant position you know extra tags
were needed inside this HTML it's good
for staff there's all sorts of things
you could do with let's add a few more
tags and it goes without saying that the
Netscape editions were totally different
to the Internet Explorer editions and
this whole thing that we covered in the
last video about the underlying
technology of sgml allowing you to a
Mitch tag so long as you thought it was
safe to do so well guess what Netscape
and Internet Explorer had different and
MIT ability specifications and one way
or another it meant that a thing that
worked beautifully in Nets
was going to fall over all over the
place in Internet Explorer what was to
be done about this
there was no standards body at the time
so they were doing their own thing but
in the meantime the opposing army was a
bunch of people who'd been with sgml
ever since day one and loved it dearly
and we're very fond of carrying around
this book as if it was a sort of some
kind of precious holy book this had the
full spec things really started going
downhill when one of the theologians
held us up poor Jeff shout from that
scripture if only you would read this
carefully from cover to cover before you
wrote a single line of code we'd be in a
lot better state than we are now
oh boy yes and of course it was the
immediate response saying some of us
buddy don't have ten years to take in
all of this stuff and then the got even
worse as I said the difficulty that you
people are in ie and Netscape with all
this and you know it took Tim a while
for us to convince him you must give a
speck of when the tags are in
permissible you must give the speck of
what to legal tag we call this a DTD a
document type definition such a shame
that people never thought to write one
of these properly before they started to
code and so the guy said look are you
seriously saying that it's not just
checking whether this markup inside a
web page forms a tree and a sequence you
want us to be looking all the time the
tag says spec to see what's immiscible
and what isn't yes of course said the
theologians you know in unison of course
you keep the DTD with you while you're
parsing the man from netscape did it
john mcenroe you cannot be you cannot be
serious you want me to be looking over
my shoulder all the time at the language
spec while I'm just trying to display
some ho by the way said lead theologian
something else we ought to mention when
you get a partly correct web page but
with mistakes you're displaying part of
it to people don't do that total
disbelief on the other camp Gorge open
what do you want us to do easy behave
like a compiler issue an error report
say error in a webpage /p tagged emitted
when this is not allowed or something
like this just like a compiler you know
above all said the high priest you
display nothing because if you display
something when it's incorrect it leads
to bad habits and I think as you said to
me many a time Jean
what kind of real world with these
people living in because of course with
this being an interpreted system Evan is
very excited about webpages you are
going to go for the browser manufacturer
who tolerates your inadequacies because
we're gonna hand coded webpages now if
it tolerates you and gives you some idea
of what's happening and you can sort of
see where I must have gone wrong fine
but to sort of end up with a great long
list of compiler error messages saying
you know your page is deficient try
again recompile and so on it's obviously
not going to go down well I can imagine
if Safari or Firefox or Chrome just
didn't display anything because it was a
mistake on it I'm not going to use that
browser know exactly so and I mean the
other thing that the high priests were
getting really obsess about was you will
all nodes inside a well-constructed web
page now you open a P and you're close a
pay for a paragraph but inside that you
say oh I want all of this to be in bold
so you open up a bold tag and you should
close the bold tag but what happens if
you do it in the wrong order you're
welcome to pay you open a B but then
instead of closing B and closing P you
do that that's called an overlapping
hierarchy you turn off paragraph before
we turn off though you should be the
other way around
cade absolutely furious
you are allowing overlapping hierarchies
and just ignoring them all this kind of
stuff re oh it was wonderful and to my
great dismay I actually had to leave the
meeting early believe it or not later
that day I was flying down from
Edinburgh to Birmingham because I was
down somewhere to give a talk about PDF
it was essentially a very similar one to
the one had given in Edinburgh so I went
away just thought this is incredible but
realizing that this was a watershed it
was really the meeting to be at and when
you looked at the title of it you know
is it poison or panacea HTML panacea of
course is a Greek word I think for a
cure-all isn't that a cure for all ills
I think is what it is and it was a very
good choice of title and it was the most
significant confrontation I think I've
ever been to in my life and I think Tim
sent me an email afterwards or maybe
somebody tell me about this but anyway I
got a message they had to go to
Birmingham cursing having to get the
plane and I said well what happened he
said easy tell them all they were all
correct and took them off to the pub I
bought lots of pints of beer we had a
very good meeting that went on into the
evening and what Tim asked was for John
Bozak of Sun Microsystems and Timbre a
very respected sgml user and guru to
please lead a committee of experts first
of all actually for HTML itself
please will you write me a DTD I know I
should have done one but can is it
possible to write a DTD so this makes it
sgml complied but then can you tackle
the problem of saying sgml is
problematical because it allows a mitad
end tags plus all sorts of other things
minor things can you within 18 months no
more do a very quick report on how to do
a subset of full sgml this cleaner which
insists on end tags being there which
doesn't allow as sgml does for the fact
that
era PA RA in capitals is treated as
being the same as PA RA in a lowercase
this is a hangover from punch-card days
you see where everything tended to end
up in uppercase anyway and all sorts of
other horrendous things about you could
put pointy bracket comments in the
middle of a tag declaration various
other more specialized nightmares which
I'll put out for you in accompanying
notes to go with this video and
basically it was agreed we've got to get
this out quickly this what came to be
known as XML and though as good as a
word I think was 1996 when the first XML
draft spec was delivered they came up
with two things they came up with XML
which is the subset the clean abstract
subset but the second thing they did
while they were at it is to say right
we've done you a DTD for the sgml
version of HTML we we wrote you the DTD
team that you should are in years ago
but just notice how much cleaner and
nicer the tag set spec is when we do it
with XML and we don't let emitted any
tags happen ever
either and everybody was convinced I
said oh who cares about extra disk space
it doesn't cost anything these days
these kind of conferences and panel
discussions and confrontation do they
accomplish as much as a night in the pub
I think you needed both you needed the
you needed a full and frank exchange of
opinions but then you needed a calming
down period with lots of beer in the pub
and I think the assertion that actually
there was right on both sides is
absolutely correct a lot of good lessons
were learned from that and yeah I think
it was Tim and others but they chose
well in asking John Bozak of Sun and
timbre some very respected authorities
to actually try and get the basic tank
set technology sorted the XML to be a
proper subset of sgml and
in one of the requirements in the
requirements spec it says brevity is to
be of minimal importance in other words
don't go bananas about missing out all
your end tags because it has the size of
your files we don't care anymore if
they're tough to parse fine and the
thing of course that they ended up with
in XML was what the browser people
wanted all along
to say I don't need to know the full tag
set spec in the first instance I just
want to check if what you've given me
that all the tags match and it's a tree
I don't care what it says in the tags
but do they match up correctly to form a
tree structure I don't need to have the
DTD to tell if it's tree structure
whereas with HTML you did so there we
are the power of several pints of beer
and it wonderful so this one is a five
because that's the bigger one this one
it's a three and this one it's the six
so now the and if it all works
well then abc.com would respond with the
corresponding web page now as you can
see